okay it's kicking off we are at this is
a one minute warzone rated average
rating 1825 here we go Premium
Membership required to play this one
double the cube
let's roll here we are gonna go fishing
and wow I'd actually have some more time
here I could um I should just fella
Queen c7 right away am I getting this
pod Knight takes Knight takes pawn not
so fast
hang on I need to take good care of the
d6 square and that's now you take care
of it that's how you allow the knight to
get there okay this is scary
it's definitely scary that's not good
kill the bishop kill the bishop kill the
bishop is the name of the game here get
rid of him go rid of this pawn right
here and that's it smooth sailing after
that kill the bishop kill the pond the
Queen in the center hitting everything
it's me if the King goes to f2 you know
you want to go to f2 let's trade Queens
I could have also taken on g3 let's keep
it simple keep it simple silly give a
check grab a bishop get your king up get
your rook on b8 don't do anything fancy
in here double the rooks double trouble
double ROK's double trouble coming up
recapture I can maybe pre-move a rook to
b3 and then take that guy there down on
time back to tournament 2 1 1 1 and then
bunch of goose eggs ok alig aleksandr
OGG
all right let's go with this I want to
get in f4 and then Knight f3 okay let's
do this you need to protect that pond
let's go tonight you know you want to do
that let's do this
it's Castle I Bishop out my Queen to d2
I roped a d1 pinpoint the d6 pine is the
plan and you also don't want to lose
material either let's do this right now
otherwise that pond might have fallen
real soon
what a pain alright let's do this dark
square Bishop was long gone my knight is
finding comfort right here on d5 and now
we got some nasty stuff happening I
could have done that actually a move
sooner but this is working it's working
mate threat watch out h7 is on h7 is
still on break this down I could have
also just taken there right away that
would have been good plenty of time to
finish this one off here chop chop
actually that's not chop that's a Czech
hit a rook give a check clean-up on look
for matin one two three four three four
back to tournament six five to dogus is
in second Oh Nona fries Nona fries is
here and I have black against Nona I
should have played e5 sooner let's go
night you need to go let's do this maybe
c4 now let's come back here I want to
get to this efore square make that
happen please it's Castle looks a little
scary but we're gonna work with it
and I didn't really want to allow night
takes I should have gone there maybe I
shouldn't have and I shouldn't take that
pile let's just get here because if I
take that pine then that Bishop would
have some daylight along that dark
diagonal I'm here are they gonna give up
the dark square bishop I'm getting this
pawn now it's come here get over here
rook you know that's an open file I have
two on it they're gonna give up the dark
square bishop the dark square Bishop is
gone so what does this mean it means I'm
in a fork right now actually it doesn't
I could do this Manji too and it's
missed back to tournament that's a mate
twelve six six five here we go all right
this guy's a beast
this guy's a beast and I just have
doubled pawns here doubled pawns it's
all I have
I'm gonna take that I'm gonna take this
I don't hang on to that guy I think that
could be a nine
I think trade Queens thank you what do
you do about your beep on it's got to be
uncomfortable right it's gotta be look
at that see five pun get out of there
rug okay
what's aah double ponds everywhere
everybody loves doubled pawns ops
colored bishop bending all right let's
try this okay what's the deal here hang
on over here you know you want to be
over here rook I'll just take that pawn
take that pawn he was free over here I'm
gonna take there you're gonna move that
pond watch out for the tricky rook
I was ready to play age seven can you
believe that one
hang on they were being sneaky where's
the mate give a check
there's no mates I'm gonna pond they
can't defend it with their king I got
this guy
what's the clock situation right here I
want to push up right here everything is
glued together and this rook has no
business being where he is no business
let's try that pawn push all right let's
see if I can make this work
this is dead draw isn't it I'm gonna try
and be sneaky sneaky 'no snick enos
sneakiness ah I was being sneaky back to
tournament 2012 11 watch out for those
sneaky moves be afraid of the sneaky
moves alrighty
Illinois 22 let's roll Smith more gambit
all right I feel like playing gambits
I'm feeling a bit reckless I also still
have this up my sleeve I now take a
knight double the pawns give me the G
file G file coming up
G files right ah I'm not so sure I want
to go with a six and B five because of
that a4 idea don't want you dare bother
my clean like that
let's go uh-oh
why'd I do that oh that's why I did it
it's working out with check let's come
back here I am wasting a lot of time
let's try this ooh ooh G to learn G to
ler rook c1 I'm just gonna play this no
matter what I'm okay with tonight here
I'm gonna give up my queen yup she's
gone
it's official she's gone but but matin
once right do you see it making one
thread check me
that's a pinned pun on g2 you gotta
watch out for those tricky pins tricky
pins everywhere this guy again
let's try something different it's like
this this is different let's do that get
that f7 pond actually let's try this I
don't know if these are the right first
moves but we're gonna give them a go we
need to rip t1 or e1 since I mouse
slipped it if you mouse leopard just go
with it I got to do that actually ok
let's do this I was fearful of Knight f4
stuff hopefully this Bishop can't do
anything exciting Queens are gonna come
off Queens gonna come off oh I just
dropped stuff darn it darn it that
didn't happen you didn't see that you
didn't see that you didn't see that you
didn't see that I just dropped that
piece like that tricky tactics
everywhere all right take that pawn it's
probably good but Oh bad news ahead bad
news no I need to keep some fuel on the
board get over here
no over here clean there what's
happening Queen right here
but bothering me I want to get over here
get out of there clean I'm gonna have to
trade Queens real soon really really
soon quit trying to trade quit trying to
trade what I do mate to threaten the
Cheka ruski hang on oh there's Queen
takes pawn I'm a dead man I'm a dead man
what am I let me throw a check-in I
can't do that move I uh I can't do that
move either I'm dead
give a check can I get this rep sucked
oh I could have done some better time
burners than that ah man
why'd I have to follow up with Knight to
e5 I was stupid I was a big dummy man ah
I didn't like losing that one at all
being too careless too careless
that's what I get you be careless you
drop a piece and you have to deal with
it now you have to live with the fact
that you just dropped your knight in the
middle game so go cry in a corner it's
your own fault you have nobody else to
blame but maybe your mouse so that
wasn't a mouse slip that was not a mouse
live don't you dare try blaming your
mouse again okay let's get this pawn cuz
he's free or is e night right there is
wonderful and what is not wonderful as
this night is gonna kill me ah what a
tough guy that Knight is he is a tough
guy what is my queen think she's doing
wow what does she think she is doing
just working I think it works no it
doesn't what pieces are dead grab the
Queen and then the bishop you got this
it's all good grab the Queen ah
man they missed it that was a free piece
now I'm up a piece oh man I am showering
my opponents with free pieces there are
free pieces flying everywhere in this
tournament give a check rook up and over
or just take free pieces you could do
that too
take free pieces give a check it's close
to me let's do this
just take that I want to get at the king
just take the rook you know you want to
fall into a self mate
actually it's mate here next that's me
back to tournament 40 can I somehow
still get this I should well I have
possibilities done 42 is a first place a
lot of time left no worries no worries
right plenty of time to hang another
piece there's plenty of time you could
at least hang another three pieces Oh
let's pin this Knight let's queenside
castle maybe yeah I'm definitely feeling
very reckless during the stream pieces
are gonna be dead pieces are gonna be
hung left and right let's go
Bishop checks Knight B fives queenside
castle throw knight on d5 grab this pond
got a bit this pond get in g4 open up
the H file can take my light square
bishop I want that H file up and up
where's the main around my queen
take that pond I want the H file to open
up quit bothering my queen i d5 and then
I'm on e7 take this pollen he's good you
know you want to take that let's take
this first and then this
now this vision needs to go before it
kills me right here okay what's going on
with that my nights covering a lot of
stuff
let's go night here hitting the rook
hitting the Queen pivot points back rank
mates a giant thorn f6 is a giant thorn
oh man you know you want to take this
rook and I better not play back here and
now I could do that I'm not gonna take
the rook I hear right here grab this
pawn called a day the down on time back
to tournament 71 5442 15 minutes left
okay let's roll here I need to get I
need to do what okay let's get on this
diagonal before they do
No look oh I should I should just hit
them with the fork hit them with a fork
if they try that again be five right
away that would have been beautiful
Castle let's do it now gonna double the
pawns just this is good this is good
this is good both sets of rooks coming
off its Knight get out there okay this
square is available it's a little scary
or a lot scary where is this night going
pressure on the night pressure on the
Queen pins everywhere be afraid of the
pins uh-oh f2 under heavy heavy heavy
fire pile up pile up pivot points don't
you dare try and get rid of that Knight
he's too good to me pressure here
pressure here pins over here Knight
coming back to hit f2 discovered tricks
against the Queen I should have done
that right away let's see if they go
back into it they did I got the Queen
let's take this rook first
and then take the queen and then
everything should be smooth sailing
smooth sailing looking for tricky mates
let's do this first let's get some more
out of it give a check got this night
and then eventually when the bishop
moves it's gonna be me and it is me back
to tournament 89 is in first eighty nine
seventy sixty four let's go alright
efore recoup quick mate catch them in a
pre move maybe maybe maybe maybe all
right I'm coming over in this direction
you've seen it before
Queenie one oh hang on hang on whoa
that's a free pawn f5 right around the
corner how does black finish up with
development let's go ecigs heavy fire on
e6
Oh can't Castle f7 is a problem this is
leading to me I know I just dropped a
piece take with the King know if he goes
here it's me he's not going there though
wow what did I tell you pieces are
falling everywhere
I should have blocked as well that would
have been right Forks multiple Forks
where the mates discovered tricks double
check I got the Queen at least what's
the clock situation just take that it
looks right kill the king kill the
knight he's gluing everything together
he's a pinned Knight
what am i doing what am i doing check of
Rooskies grab the rook on g8 this would
have been better go check grab this guy
we're not
what's the clock count quit bothering my
queen are you doing clock clock clock
alright I need to go quicker here let's
grab this and that grab this night no no
no no no no no no does that mean it's
all there down on time Wow
why do you have to get so close cuz you
dropped pieces
that's why quit droppin pieces and it
won't be as close maybe alright I don't
have to do a six there's no night that's
gonna come there Oh
what is white doing alright where is the
Queen gonna go watch out for the pins
I'm gonna end up in a fork for karu ski
Oh forks forks everywhere I just drop
tonight this is a disaster I'm not doing
these are not on purposes either by the
way these are not on purposes these are
just real blunders blunders in action
right here Wow oh man
let's castle I can't castle yes I could
castle come on you know you want to take
that pun I have something here Knight
takes is good it's a winning move ah
they didn't do it though it was a
deflection I would have been dropping
the whole house right there King
position rook position and down I'm down
him oh I'm down a full rook now
this is ridiculous man come on this is
my last time burner the last warrior
right here this is all I have launched
the pawns no don't you dare try and
trade let's do that this is so bad this
is bad news okay
oh man I gotta do this I need to save
that rook he's really important to me
pig
there's pigs there's one pig here I
should be very scared no ha ha you dare
try and make me no don't you dare the
king is running he's been released the
King is running crazy you can't get him
now or can you I need to hang onto the
last time burner that was my last time
burner don't you dare get mated pre
moves where are they they're down on
time my time but it's the best friend my
best friend is the time once again ah
what an ugly one to have to win there
let's see if I can not hang a piece that
I'm struggling just not hanging pieces
in this tournament eight minutes left
somehow somehow I have to UM what am i
disguise and this is that though this is
the top guy this is the top guy okay
hang on oh hang on please don't hang a
piece whatever you do do not hang pieces
Oh we'll just take him okay
don't hang pieces whatever you do don't
hang pieces this game just don't hang
pieces this game please let's double up
here take that night you know you want
to take him so I could get here yes you
did want to take them okay okay okay
hang on out this night getting excited
about that square hang on double up over
here what's the clock situation hang on
don't you dare hang on don't you dare
give that pot up whoa my opponents
wanting a draw I don't want to draw
let's take that I want to get that a
pawn and make that happen no they don't
I don't want to draw I have a better
idea
sneaky sneaky this kink position King
position right here Queen position ah oh
I have a plan I have a plan this first
and then this and then this
I'm dropping a lot of puns hopefully
it's okay is it okay they only have 12
seconds am i getting made it let's give
a check it's it this bishop am I getting
made it my King is once again running
for the hills
Oh what happened there the king is he's
weaseling about he's a weasel er they
resigned back to tournament that was
clutch I needed that they hit a speed
bump what 47 128 that's what I needed
right there this is the guy that should
give me a beating wasn't it I think it
might have been the guy that should have
gave me a beating last time yeah it was
they did this same setup last time I'm
not gonna chop pieces this time
hopefully they're dropping a pond though
hang on hang on not so fast not so fast
all right Queen you need to go you
definitely need to go Bishop takes pawn
is available because I'm in a pin
actually win event cuz I'd bond the
Queen if that happened okay big trouble
for the Queen pawn push in the center
hitting the Queen getting ready to kick
the night away I'm dropping that
it's okay insignificant pond this one
however is significant and I just
dropped him more dropped pieces but now
he's not dropped he's in a pen follow-up
fork tkl actually take here if the
knight moves i take here and get the
queen oh oh that's a problem i got to
clean this is our time to resign four
minutes and change can i get this i need
to focus on these next couple games
quick wins I should just take in that
night and a pin let's take that pile up
here I'm just gonna do that I think
they're gonna get out of that pin
they're gonna weasel out king c2 right
what else would there be right here my
d3 that give a check I don't want any
time to come off my clock right here
does that mean it's close to me yeah
anything okay the games not gonna finish
is it okay down that time 177 oh that
guy keeps winning 177 148 3 minutes and
change can I somehow get this come on
you know you could get it let's go here
is there one quick resigner in the house
I need some cheap tricks
cheap tricks have seven cheapos I'm out
this and this maybe oh let's go let's
roll here g5 Oh mate threatmate
threatmate threat made threat weird are
they gonna resign yes they resigned back
to tournament 177 once 168 come on come
on that guys ready to win maybe uh what
do we have three minutes left
a quick winner here hopefully what can
you do I need to kick this night away
okay
this night I'm gonna flush this night
away okay Castle kingside you know you
want to do that the pressure over here
bishop now I should play Bishop d7 let's
guard this pawn and a push that night
away right now and get to the h-file I
should take care o that's falling isn't
it okay discover tricks I got to defend
that and stuff queenside castle can I
get that in what's the time two minutes
left this game is not going to end soon
I get that
Matt bishop what's oh it's a free bishop
are they gonna resign just resign come
on one minute 15 don't you dare try and
get down there with the rooks you grab
that guy I'm gonna push this pawn okay
push this pawn to Victory Lane Victory
Lane come on come on come on come on
come on you know this is beat okay they
reside back to tournament 197 I need to
get this one one minute 26 25 24 23 I
have to win this within 20 seconds to be
assured that I could get this win 20
seconds I have just to make sure I could
win I do this I get this in take that
pawn if they Castle or I could take it
now I'm on the Queen come on I want this
to blow up real quick what's the what's
the plan no no no no I'm dropping that
pond I'm dropping that bishop
take care I'm on the Queen I'm on g7 46
seconds left it's not happening no I
should take the bish up Forks I got it
again mate mate mate mate I need to get
him in a mate is this mate this is close
to me where's the mean is this double
check and then where's the main where's
the mate where's the mate where's the
main they're not gonna move where's the
main I'm being sneaky those are gonna be
a mate soon just just take just take
just take just take take take take take
take yes yes yes 208 uh-huh doesn't
matter
ah it doesn't matter oh I got that last
wind but it wasn't enough that guy won
what can you do Oh 18 games in the guy
had good tournament good tournament
these games oh okay
227 208 182 120 all right let's close
shop good tournament to do vid first
place and then my row with the third up
there good player as well okay let's
close out